this is a production of cornell
university
so helping our students step off the
hamster bill writing as an approach to
foster reflection this presentation will
be talking about reflections why it
matters
how we've lost it and how to use some
tools to incorporate reflection into the
classroom based on center for teaching
excellence
assistance that i've gotten so what is
reflection
i'll use the definition causing to
consider action in an effort to engage
in a process of continuous learning
so i want to emphasize continuous
whether we're riding a bike or sitting
in a cornell classroom we're reflecting
on our learning sometimes without even
being conscious of it and that involves
asking questions like what happened what
was my response how do i make sense of
it how does it relate to other stuff i
know
what can i conclude and i find this to
be important what might i do differently
next time so this is ongoing i really
appreciate the words of john dewey
educational visionary who pointed out
that we don't learn from experience we
learn from reflecting on it
so given the importance of reflection
and that it's ongoing and it's a part of
our learning it makes sense that we
would deliberately include included in
our teaching experience in the classroom
it's so important
to our you know learning experience i
appreciate this student's perspective
she said i have a difficult time talking
about myself and i don't often pause to
consider my strengths and weaknesses she
went on to say that reflection really
impacted her because she was applying
for jobs and this helped her think about
her strengths and weaknesses put her
best foot forward let's pull that word
out of her quote for those words don't
often pause i don't know about you but
it seems to me that none of us are
pausing these days we're doing and doing
and doing without causing in fact it
almost seems as if we've grown
uncomfortable that not we're not doing
we're doing so much we're too busy in
fact tim kreider and the busy trap had
this to say almost everyone i know is
busy they feel anxious and guilty when
they aren't either working or doing
something to promote their work they're
busy because of their own ambition or
drive they're addicted to busyness and
dread what they might have to face in
its absence
does this sound familiar to any of you
and again i don't think it's just our
our university students i think it's all
of us it's a cultural problem
we're all doing too much we have too
much on our plates i think about one
student it broke my heart what she had
to say about all of this
she went on to tell us that in her view
i'm no longer able to express myself as
i once did because i'm too tense and too
critical to let myself go i lost the
flow somewhere between the labs and
all-nighters and term papers and prelims
to the point where it's extremely
difficult to bring myself either to
tears or satisfaction this is not what
we want to see in our student body and
one way to change it up a little bit is
through writing i want to point out
reflective writing is deliberate it's
intentional it's not just accidental
they're not just sort of writing about
whatever or keeping a diary it's a very
deliberate part of the classroom
experience it's important that we stage
it that way to get the most out of it
for our students
this includes well-planned rubrics clear
guidelines sample writings of what we
want to see
prompts that help students know what it
is you're trying to pull out of them and
then in class experiences that can
support that out of class writing and
reflection
this is a very deliberate approach let's
talk about rubrics so a good rubric
focuses on learning
improves the clarity of the feedback
reinforces our expectations and i really
appreciated this this semester with a
team of tas enables multiple graders to
evaluate work really consistently across
the board
students can use a rubric to assess
their own work rubrics engage students
in the learning process
and so they can describe what's expected
of them and ultimately we hope this
improves their motivation i have sample
rubrics if they're of help to anyone
feel free to take a look have them over
on the table
i'd like a developing scale because what
i'm after is the development of student
writing over time i want to see that
growth and we use three points for
reduced subjectivity if you have a group
of graders in particular we're going to
agree on one two or three whereas one to
ten might be really challenging and be
more subjective
guidelines are important too and they
ought to begin with why why are we doing
this reflective writing is for students
not for us
and it helps them identify their
challenges and areas of ambiguity and
really sort out what they're learning
and it also connects back with the
rubric so these two together are very
robust and very powerful
sample writings kind of show students
exactly what you're looking for from
them you can offer a here's a high
quality paper here's one not so much and
here's one that really is a reflection
at all so they can see exactly what's
expected of them if they and you are new
to reflection this could be very very
helpful
um meaningful props are important too
what they do is offer an assignment
often one of depths students can sink
their teeth into then help them step
back and assess the classroom experience
what they're reading what they're doing
in labs the whole
classroom
dynamic so you're giving them a really
toothy time and then just some other
considerations to support reflective
writing
occasional in-class free writing pausing
after 10 or 15 minutes of presentation
having them write right right and then
hand it in to you
can have you see how they're assessing
what's happening in the classroom can
almost be a dialogue to let you know
what they're really grasping peer review
is helpful as well
so from this presentation i realized i'm
going to put my money where my mouth is
and the last two slides i'd like you to
just pause for a moment and then this
very quick six minute presentation just
reflect on what did you get out of it
what resonated with you
anything new or surprising
anything that didn't resonate with you
just pause for a few moments and think
about you know what what did you get
from your presentation
thank
start
a couple of questions i want you to
think about who you are as a teacher
that's american reference or pretty one
an informational textbook
manual are you nothing more than a book
are you an unput adaptable
masterpiece when you teach
or are you something a little more
extraordinary
as a teacher
i want to talk today about literacy and
it builds on what marsha was talking
about it's like we had this plan um but
just a little background what we do is
work with folks who want to be public
school teachers for us that's important
because public high school students will
soon be our students and we have this
thing called common core state standards
adopted by 46 states across the nation
they ask students to read and write
differently than they ever have in the
past up to 70 percent of that reading
and writing at the
senior level will be informational text
with a task like that
where students read a couple of articles
about biofuels for example and then have
to find one other source of their own
take a stand on the issue and then write
a policy paper to a local policy maker
scores will be based on things like the
position the comprehensiveness the
support organization clarity fluency and
then editing for grammar and usage
and this is one of our teachers that we
work with amazing how
my students immediately jumped into it
read it we're excited about being asked
to approach the reading from a different
perspective and share out with their
with their group members
it was really it was it was very
empowering and wonderful to see them
actually reading the content for the
first time
crystal's referencing some of the
literacy strategies we've used in her
high school classes that could be
adaptable to a college course one of the
strategies is this thing called a
concept of definition map it's just
simply a graphic
organization in your teaching i'd
encourage you to think about that in our
publications we use models those are
graphic organizers this is a different
one a frayer model
what we know today as a teacher you know
a lot of ways can be found
on these kind of contraptions how we
learn is by manipulating that
information and so i took the concept of
powdery mildew and thought about uh what
it might be confused with some symptoms
some cures some prevention another kind
of a graphic organizer is a venn diagram
i tried something
i just remember the hops presentations i
went with what i knew ales and lagers
and you know just comparing and
contrasting
most of our literacy strategies or
there's a growing body of researchers
who say of the thousands of literacy
strategies you can use it might not be
such a big deal which strategy used as
long as you use something where students
are manipulating transforming the
information here's another kind of a
graphic organizer comparison contrast
map
down the middle we have our criteria
that we want to assess two different
kinds of ideas where should i focus my
teaching attention content or process
and we compare the two one of my
favorites that i've used
anytime i have a struggling student in
class is cornell notes you probably i'm
gonna use cornell notes
shame on you we teach here um so we have
a section for the notes that the
students would write in class
at home tonight they'll write a keyword
index and then tomorrow before class
they come in and write a two or three
sentence summary of that information so
they touch the information at least
three and probably four times because
they've listened to you once another
strategy our teachers have used like
crystal are things called admit or exit
passes might tie into marsha's
reflective writing
it's anonymous use index card to the
beginning or the end of class
those are the admit or exit passes
so if they're usually beginning in class
it's an admissions ticket into the class
the end of class it's an exit pass you
might ask questions like what did you
learn today
what are the confusing points about
today's lecture or yesterdays then what
questions still remain after we've
discussed this so it gives you immediate
feedback on your teaching episodes
changing teaching practices is not easy
as we found working with high school
teachers i guess it's fairly similar
here one of the criteria is fostering a
sustaining community of practice
not every day are things going to go
exactly as planned we master face
reality that we're not we're plant
scientists not rocket scientists
and we approach literacy the writing the
reading not as it is good teaching but
it's essential to what we do
we're experts in horticultural fields we
read and write we use information
it helps students
maybe a mistake to go totally wireless
you may have to use some of writing
which is an old-fashioned i carried a
pencil to a meeting a minute ago and the
lady said what is that i guess it's a
pencil
seriously um it began with authentic
horticulture learning not with the
literacy
because those common core state
standards when we're working with high
school teachers they want to force
reading and writing into everything it's
just not natural it needs to be
authentic read and write where it makes
sense in your classroom but do so in a
way that you can maximize the academics
the reading writing the reflection that
is actually embedded in learning good
horticultural science and practice
takes time and effort and so if marvin
wants you to teach a new class that
takes time if you want to adapt your
practice of teaching that takes time as
well because it's uncomfortable the
first couple times you try reflection or
try a graphic organizer out with your
students they feel the awkwardness and
tension you feel but after a while
teachers that we are i think literacy
has a role to play
in our teaching practice
thank
you for making me get outside of my
comfort zone
and five
four three two
one
start
okay thank you neil
so we're going to be talking about
extension today and about the regional
teams which
have really been growing
uh even though we've had these for a
number of years i think we're really
seeing a growth today i think it's
really good news in fact i think there's
some
better news about extension and what's
happening in extension than we've seen
in many years
there's a lot of people here in this
audience that probably don't realize
what it means to be in a land-grant
institution we have a lot of students
here and i just want to make sure we're
all on the same page
really focusing on the smith weber act
which established extension throughout
the united states even though a lot of
states were doing that previous to 1914
and new york was starting to celebrated
our 100th anniversary this year 1912.
the difference between a regional and
county-based
is that again county-based tended to be
a generalist they might do everything
from working with animals to working in
4-h to working in crops as compared to a
person over here in most counties i
threw a picture of bob becker up there
for those of you that remember him bob
was my
predecessor in the job and worked a lot
with setting up regional teams you can
see that we've got right now in new york
10 regional teams 34 specialists that
number is going to be going up
but what's missing ornamental
horticulture we do not have an
ornamental horticulture team and that's
something i think we really need to
change in the future i'm not sure what
the history of that is that's caused
that you can see here just some on the
upper left-hand side we see where the
cornell vegetable program the counties
that they're working in over in eastern
new york we've got
counties that the vegetable team is
working in
the big news is that as of january 1st
we're starting a new horticulture team
that's going to go from very northern
counties in clinton all the way down to
putnam in ulster county
and that's going to cover not only a lot
of counties but include a lot of
specialists as well
how are they funded ideally in a perfect
world 72 percent of the funding was
supposed to come from counties 20 from
cornell and 8 had to be generated by the
team members
reality is that the county money has
been going down
significantly
and that the program generated income or
the amount of money that's being raised
through grants primarily through grants
has skyrocketed and the teams are being
very very successful in getting it
outside monday
in terms of how we set these teams up
the
vegetable team which is the one i'm most
familiar with that most have similar
setups is a leadership team with mark
giles who should get a lot of credit for
the growth of the regional teams
answering to us answering to
like a game show here
advantage is a regional program there
certainly are advantages to that people
get to specialize salaries are hired we
retain their people for a longer period
of time
the technology we have allows for better
connectivity between the people out of
the campus and campuses
why now recession has made the counties
really rethink how they're funding their
programs and that's probably been the
most important thing that's happened the
success of existing teams the teams that
are out there are doing very well the
stakeholders want to see those teams
expanding
certainly the faculty losses since 1994
which was the year i was hired so
there's nothing magical about that
because these are the people that were
lost just in vegetable crops in the
horticulture ithaca and geneva
we'd have a similar thing if we looked
at ornamental port or fruit
this is what we've gained
two good people in anu and phil
griffiths but again we've lost 10.
um we've gained two
so where is that expertise going to come
from
we've heard from young nairo we're not
going to be hiring additional people
here
on a campus level in fact we're going to
be going down
so
we've got to be looking outside the box
who's going to be doing a lot of the
applied field work that was being done
in 1994 on the left side are names of
people that working in extension at that
time
over here on the right side you see the
people that are working here now quite a
difference between what we lost in
faculty
and what has been an extension
and what remains an extension that is
growing so
again the extension folks are the ones
that are really stepping up to do a lot
of the applied research
research component is expected
developing a regional national
reputation is expected grant writing and
success in garnering those grants and
publishing all those things are going to
be expected from these people and they
are doing that okay so for example we've
got judd who's really taking a statewide
leap and working in high tunnels christy
hopking with the retirements of faculty
has taken over a lot of the onion work
that was being done in the field chuck
bourne again doing a lot of the
equipment work over the capital district
and crystal stewart
has been the one that stepped forward to
lead the working garlic okay so these
are all regional extension specialists
that are doing work that a lot of the
faculty was doing before invasive
species becoming more and more important
these folks are there on the front line
and working with the faculty putting
together those programs to try to be
able to be proactive when it comes to
sweet midge or drosophila or a stink bug
all those things there are challenges
the counties want to know what are you
doing for me in my county i'm so funding
this
what am i getting
outside funding will it be enough has
been the vegetable team last year at 32
different grants five member team that
brought it over 500 thousand dollars
total of grants for these so again the
money does seem to be there they are
doing very successful
will they have the expertise the
training the background
and the facilities to go beyond just the
old research that's going to be a
problem
we'll be able to keep up with the
technological innovations again
not sure
i have to add ornamental horticulture to
these teams either create a ornamental
horticulture team or add these people to
the existing teams which is a i think a
good way to go as well
and finding qualified people has been
one of the hardest things that we've had
we've just gone through two searches to
try to find a person to join our
vegetable team in western new york and
we still have not found the right person
for that
so again the jobs are going to be out
there we need qualified people with at
least a master's degree
that have some training in horticulture
and i think i'm really excited about the
people that we've got out there right
now
and hopefully some of you in this
audience here some of the students will
think about a career in extension
are we limited to just 20 second
questions
do you foresee that these regional teams
are going to cross state boundaries and
what are the barriers to that
i that's a good question i don't see
them crossing state barriers yet
we still have a problem and an issue
it's been hard enough to get over the
county boundaries
and
there have been some attempts to go over
state boundaries and we do have that on
one of the the great teams
with penn state but it is much harder
and i just don't see that happening in
the foreseeable future
maybe if we get into one more really bad
recession
maybe we'll start to see some of that
but i don't see that soon
i'm curious about you know the approach
that travis and marcia presented in
terms of
reflection and writing law and then
steve's approach here we talk about
these regional teams i'm wondering
whether you're familiar with steve with
any attempts to sort of use these higher
level
thinking skills and learning skills and
extension it seems to me most of the
time
we get to give presentations or we talk
and we sit down
but the evidence shows that these other
types of learning actually are more
meaningful and more in-depth but i'm not
aware of anyone's been great enough to
go beyond just the superficial
presentation of information extension i
wonder if the regional teams think about
pedagogy and alternate ways presenting
that might move in a direction it's a
little bit more reliable we can try in
the classroom
the short answer would be no really you
know it's more of the sort of getting up
there being a book and just imparting
the information and then sitting down um
it certainly is going to be the next
step but i don't think i've really seen
any extension presentations that have
been like that
do you mind if i respond to that really
quickly too
you know it's also unfortunate that
those of us you know i feel like i
noticed it with both the teaching and
extension
component to my work i have incredible
resources on campus in the center for
teaching excellence to guide me in
preparing my courses but you know it's
interesting that we kind of don't have
that equivalent and extension
and you know maybe maybe someday that
will change that they'll have
because that really does help to get us
outside the box and help us
it would be nice to have a similar sort
of community of learners on campus
marcia
i think sometimes
reflection has been considered sort of
touchy feely or something and that's why
i was very pleased to see you make
explicit characteristics of you know
but do you think a reflection can be
applied to of course more technical
course like say plant physiology or in
chemistry absolutely that's a that's a
great question and i have like three
things that are popping into my head at
once um and i'll try to sort them in
order
uh you know what what that brings to my
you know chems for those if everybody
heard him what about the touchy feely
thing
i've heard people say things like i'm
not really a therapist so i shouldn't
have to act like one kind of thing but
you know 50 years of brain research has
showed us
a lot has been revealed in brain
research and it showed that you know we
don't think in our brains we think in
our minds and our minds are that's a
then the mind involves processes
throughout all of us including our
feelings including the affective and our
students bring all of that to the
classroom they bring all of their
attendant human massive feelings anytime
we have more than two people in a room
we have that and in fact our learning
outcomes talk about what we should say
do think and feel so it is a part of the
class so the question is if we want to
guide that effectively
um and i think we do
so yeah i think it and it can also
reveal when we ask those kinds of
questions you know sometimes i think
people have a personal discomfort with
emotions and that's a whole other that's
a whole other quality so what how i
think we can structure reflection is is
by being being aware of our own
limitations i don't want to go over
there i mean i don't want to talk about
all that stuff and you can pose
questions think about anything in a
course that people struggle with any
concept principles practices and pose
reflective questions around that so you
know how they're processing what they're
learning so in plant physiology it might
be a certain
approach that you know students struggle
with so you can pose reflective
questions they get at that and then you
also know how they're learning what
they're learning but we can't we can't
avoid
a human being that comes into our
classroom so it makes sense that we
would organize it in a way that that
they're getting the most out of it did
that answer the question
what's the last part of your scientific
papers manuscripts that you spent the
last section it's called inclusion
that's reflections
taken broad it's reflection about very
scientific you know what
what are the implications how do we make
sense of this what other questions does
this trigger that could be a reflection
and very much science working kind of
liz
did you have a question about your admit
one or your the little things you would
take from
students on their way in or their way
out of class do you then typically
just use those for your own help or do
you then address the specifically those
the next class or how do you sort of
work with those little e-value things
both of those
ways the majority of the students hate
similar things they'll hopefully they
get the key messages of
the learning for that day's class but
then if there are questions or someone
has a misconception in the writing we'll
use that as a
reflection uh recap
at the next lecture lecture on the
previous day's
talk to bridge those two content areas
sometimes if there are enough um
questions we'd you know take a long
discussion you can turn those some of
those into a quick
quiz if you wanted to the next day but
yeah use that some way to bridge that
if they got everything there weren't
many questions
then we wouldn't use them a lot but
usually you'll know where you're going
to see students have
additional questions or points of
confusion
good question
okay
have you thought about using class time
in a different way you guys just did
these six minute kinds of presentations
our typical class periods are 55 or 75
minutes long um would you
should we think in terms of
repartitioning that like here's my first
six minutes
now we're going to have a breakout group
thing and then we're going to do some
other kind of things so that each
lecture so to speak would be a
relatively small part of that class
meeting is that
something that that you typically do in
your classes or that you can see us
going forward
i'll be i'll answer real quickly from an
art of horticulture perspective in that
class we always begin with a reflection
they're writing as they begin
then we have about a 10 or 10 to 20
minute presentation but depending on
the topic with comments from the
students that get involved with that
then we have some kind of in class
experience and then a closing
um either their writing or reflecting or
a small group of discussion or so the
actual
lecture or presentation or whatever you
know that that's a it's a
you know we know that they can't really
and none of us really pay attention
after
50 minutes
so what you're asking about
in uh teaching terms would be a flipped
classroom where there's a little bit of
lecture perhaps but a large part of the
information gathering and transmission
happens outside the class so the
students are expected to actually read
their assignments before class and then
we come in and maybe you have this kind
of thing seven eight minutes of
lecture and then yeah it's some kind of
engaging activity that's the value of
all of us
you're a lot more than the red book
bible right
cue the head nod yeah i mean
but unfortunately when we lecture that's
a lot of what we are
i am anyway i am is information
transmission and they can get that a lot
more effectively in other advantages but
i can help students problem solve and
apply information and answer questions
doing an extension you're going into a
room where you might have people that
are 18 years old might have somebody
that's 75 and
a lot of times in order and vegetables
and fruit we've got people that are
close to 75 very different ways of how
they're processing what they're getting
the folks that are younger
want are going to probably respond a lot
more and i can see that they can respond
a lot more influence you know sort of
getting input from them and stopping and
letting them talk and building consensus
if i were to do that with a group of 65
year old cabbage farmers if i stop
talking and watch
information from them they're in silence
and
it goes on for a long time
because they're not used to that so it's
it's a little bit harder i think an
extension because you're dealing with
such different requirements
yeah just uh two comments here one for
travis uh my fifth grader brought home
one of those uh
concept mapping things i didn't know
what it was but when i saw yours i
thought
yeah that's what my daughter
got in fifth grade and then
uh for steve uh just another comment i
think i think that we do do that same
sort of reflection thing but it's it's
more like you know the talks the excuse
for getting them there and then
all the action happens outside the talks
you know when they come up to you
one-on-one
and ask questions and things so i talked
to you i think it'd be a hard tough
tough to get people to you know do
writing assignments during
meetings and things like that
well the dec i mean the other thing
you're looking at too is how many people
are there for dc credits and you're
gonna have to i can't go in there
they're expecting 45 minutes of talking
about a pesticide all of a sudden after
six minutes
you just break up into smaller groups
discuss the
pesticides uh this question is for steve
i'm
fairly new to extension i definitely
feel like i am one of the younger of the
generation of extension professionals
and you said that you guys are having
challenges recruiting for your regional
teams what do you think the catch is for
attracting
younger students
from your programs or anywhere
because i kind of stumbled upon
extension i don't really know that i
ever
knew extension existed until
right i think i think that's one of the
problems is that for for many students
they're not even aware of extension
if they have an advisor that has an
extension appointment then they're going
to be aware of it but otherwise they may
not they may not realize that there are
jobs available
and you can get out there and do the
things that you really like and work
with growers and do applied research
that's a good question but i mean we're
going into our third potential search
for this position the pay is
i think competitive with any other state
if not better
there's just um awful lot of technical
information from department students
and
if you're going to cut
20 minutes out of our
50-minute class
what are you going to cut out in terms
of content you can go forward i mean
maybe that content is essential to
understanding the field and this is a
conundrum
but i don't know how to get around it
out of a 50 minute
class period
what do students actually learn in that
50 minutes i mean they're going to take
away
not every you don't you don't have 100
retention of what they learn in that 50
minutes
and honestly it's
probably less than a dozen key points
that they're going to most of them have
remember
a week down the road or two days down
the road once a weekend happens a lot of
brain cells get lost
so it yeah it's hard to give that up but
if you can transition and what aren't
these were high school teachers when
they were using some of these strategies
and they just stuck to their guns and
said okay you've got to
bring this graphic organizer in filled
out on this subject and we're going to
start there they really had to
enforce that with the students to make
them
do the work outside the class in the
reading but the students found it more
meaningful because then the lecture
wasn't just a repeat of what the book
said or something outside of class and
so if we stick to our guns and treat
class as a place we're going to do some
different kinds of learning and the
information download
how to rebuild it
right i mean i'm not an expert on
powdery mildew but i can get pretty
dangerous with the basics of powdery
mildew on my phone what you can teach me
about powdery mildew is
beyond has to be beyond looking
different
the retention is not understandable
so kind of going off at that point do
you think the whole structure of three
minute lectures or two 75-minute
lectures is really not an efficient way
of learning and should it be
more of a daily thing for smaller
classes to get students to actually
learn more information
well
it's a great question
some colleges are going with block
scheduling so that they have longer you
know you might take one course for three
and a half weeks so that you can really
sink into it
but i think that
we have a lot of creativity within the
short time frames that we have i will
say my classes i love are the ones that
are all after
i don't know that it's the length of
time it's what you do with the time that
you're given
and we learn things by
taking hold of it wrestling with it
manipulating i mean learning is is an
effortful process
one of the things we often hear people
say is one of the best ways to learn
something is to teach it right
okay that's pretty good all right but i
can break that down how many times do
you touch the content in order to
effectively stand in front of a group
without passing out falling over so you
can teach it right
do a little reading online or in a book
you prepare you take your notes from
that reading you develop an outline you
put together a powerpoint
you might check a couple of facts you
might go find pictures and video then
you actually get in front of the
students and lecture let's say they ask
some questions so yeah
apparently you've touched that content
seven times in teaching
well that's how you learn it's not that
you're teaching events because you have
these
all these different kinds of
interactions and different ways of
as marcia said being
cognitive with the thoughts being
effective being physical with your
content whatever i mean it's all of that
but together is how we learn so within
50 minutes or 75 minutes if you're just
lecturing students are getting it one
way
and that's not effective if you can
help them touch the content in multiple
modalities
with their physical and mental being but
then also you know different ways of
even cognitively touching content that's
the security can we turn a question out
to you here at the closing what did you
think about this format i mean my sense
is it's challenging for the presenter
it's
you know it forces us to do a more
succinct
job but it's
i've witnessed one of these last summer
at conference and i really liked it from
the sitting out their perspective what
do you guys think what did you think
about this yeah i think uh
it's such a concise
delivery that i have to listen to the
speaker very carefully i can't pay
attention to the slides
i can't read the slides
there were times when i wished i could
just like pause this line for like five
extra seconds
and so if it wasn't exactly
20
maybe the speaker could still control
the
the remote or something to advance the
slides but have it be close to 20
seconds per slot
can we have a show at hand should we try
it again next semester yeah
yeah who wants to volunteer
he'll ask this on monday i'm like yeah
sure seven minutes no big deal
um and i procrastinated uh and i
had the ideas rumbling around my head
for a couple of weeks and i had some of
the slides already ready to go but not
in a format that we could do the 20
seconds i sat down at one o'clock
yesterday afternoon and started working
on this presentation but i walked away
from the computer at like seven o'clock
last night so the six minute seven
minute presentation for me was probably
four solid hours
but i mean a lot of it was me going okay
i gotta clip that video i don't have the
software too i gotta find that online so
now it would be faster but i'd encourage
you to do it it really challenged it was
a fun challenge i no joke i hate neil
for the thank neil for it
but it was fun it was fun to see the
other two they did a wonderful wonderful
job
i picked one class and they're pretty
good
thank you guys
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu